thank you so yeah so before I talk about
active regression let's first out first
talk a little bit about just standard
agnostic learning so here you to see
pairs X Y sampled from some distribution
so X is the feature vector and Y is the
label that you want and here we're gonna
say that it's not zero one labels but
it's a real valued label and so you'd
like to you'd like to find the functions
of the Y is close to f of X and we'll
stick with the simplest l2 setting for
this talk and so or say that Y is close
on average and l2 and you want to find
approximation F hat to the true function
f so that Y is close to f hat or just
that f of X is close to f hat and so in
particular let's say that just the
average over your distribution of x and
y of Y minus F of x squared is bounded
by Sigma square for something Sigma that
you don't necessarily know but should be
relatively small and then the goal is to
find some approximation so that our
error the error of our of our prediction
is in most relative error constant
approximation here you go for one plus
epsilon and sometimes you can get
epsilon depending on exactly what you're
looking for how long do I have for this
talk by the way okay so this makes sense
as a goal now you could also say instead
of trying to approximate why we're just
trying to let then maybe maybe Y has
noise there's like the true signal F
that is the what you want and then
there's noise added to it you don't want
to learn that noise you just want to
learn the actual F and then you can yeah
up to constant factor contents and see
you could be saying we want F minus half
hat to be less than C and then if your
noise is mean zero you can even hope for
this C to the epsilon instead of
and so then so then this quantity here
where there's the expect the expected
squared error there's going to appear a
lot so we're just gonna call that the
norm or the strap to the distribution
yes so depends on you have supposed yeah
if you have some class of functions and
then and the algorithm is going to
depend on your class so for most of the
talk is there's gonna be a linear class
today it's relatively simple but we're
gonna talk a little bit about you know
so as far as for a class and that it's
pretty concise okay so this is the goal
now the question is how many samples
does it take and how can you efficiently
compute this agnostic learning and so
let's restrict to the linear space of
functions so right linear space so this
means that after you embed X with some
feature vector than you know that it's
just alpha transpose times Phi of X now
for example polynomials are a linear
space right there are linear functions
in the embedded space so if I have my
function is supposed to be some cubic
then we're gonna be observing Y which is
not exactly F it has some error that's
bound in L 2 and then from Y we want to
we want to get some F hat that's close
to F or close to Y either way that the
same thing and so one when you when you
when you think about this it makes sense
to then look at the inner product
between two functions in your class
which is the expected value of f of X G
of X and there's the inner product that
gives the norm that we were talking
about in the previous line that Norm
being the expected squared difference
when you think about this inner product
and now instead of thinking about as a
function from X to R we can think about
as our observations are in like a spin
infinite dimensional space where each
dimension is what is the value at x1
maddox and like every position X and so
the function class is some D dimensional
sub space of all possible functions from
r2r and then we want to and then we want
is we want to project from why you're
like observations to the space of
functions so you can think that under
the inner products we want to find
ideally we'd find like that the best F
star but because we don't have full
samples we don't really know what Y is
we have some approximation to these
inner products we're just going to get
we're going to get some f hat that's not
quite right because our a standing the
space isn't quite right we don't know
all X's we only know some subsampling of
them of this mace so then right but
because of that what we're gonna do is
rather than going to look for the point
that minimizes the expected error over
the distribution very natural thing you
can try is the empirical risk
minimization of samples just look at the
average squared error on our samples it
will output the function that minimizes
our the average squared error all the
things that we've seen so far and this
is very natural thing to do and the
question is how many samples do you need
in order for this to be good enough for
for the empirical risk manager to be
close to the actual risk minimizer so as
M converges M goes to infinity your
empirical risk is going to converge to
the actual risk and then this would be
the actual minimizer which is what do
you want you take a finite number of
samples it won't quite be there but
hopefully with relatively few samples
it'll get a good job and so we want to
do this with respect to both the
function and the noise but actually for
intuition it makes sense to just think
about it as saying we want to we want to
have the empirical norm approximate the
actual norm over functions in our class
there's a separate argument to talk
about what happens for the noise which
I'll mostly skip but so for now let's
just talk about approximating the the
norm of functions in our class
so what we want to say is okay if we
have if you have a class of functions
how many samples do we need for us to be
able to estimate the norm of the
function just as the average squared
back and so ideally we'll have it's just
that are the error that right so ideally
all we'll have is that our our
approximation F hat is within epsilon
relative to the distance to Y of the
truth of the true function our norm if
our normy comes very close then our the
projection under this slightly slightly
wrong inner product is gonna be epsilon
close to the actual projector okay so
let's be a bit more concrete let's think
about a degree 5 polynomial and our
space is that X is rent used uniformly
random between negative 1 and 1 and so
if we eat a sample at say these points
maybe we see the observation zero zero
zero zero zero zero so if we see this
what are we gonna output well there's
like a zero function let's not the zero
function is actually this function and
this function is pretty close because
yes within some small value everywhere
that we've seen but it's not pretty
close to the actual zero function being
square in the l2 norm that we care about
because on this small region over here
is just very very big and so on this one
over d squared sized region its value is
like d into the expected squared
distance is some can be a large constant
even though you want a small cost of
approximation
and okay so if you think about trying to
prove about if you were to try a proof
amount here you would say that's well
the how fast does a an average converge
to its expectation it depends on the
Chernoff bound that till then say once
you take a number of samples that's
proportional to the maximum value it can
take then you're going to get a very
good approximation but here the maximum
value that you can take is quite large
and so the balance so the number of
samples you take depends on the maximum
value over all functions in your class
who's a norm is constant and the maximum
value of all X of f of x squared so this
is the ratio between the maximum value
that f of x squared can take to the
average value that f of x squared can
take and so for polynomials this is a
function whose maximum value is d so its
maximum squared value is d squared and
yet it's average value is just constant
and so it's K is d squared and that
gives you a sample complexity of d
squared for agnostic learning of degree
D polynomials and right in general you
can show that with order K log D plus K
over epsilon samples for any linear
space of functions you can do agnostic
learning in l2 and what I mean by
agnostic learning here is well if your
if your noise has mean zero then you're
going to approximate the true function
up to the true optimal function up to an
epsilon times your error and if you want
to if your noise does not mean zero then
you can't do that because my noise is
plus one everywhere but if the actual
function is zero and my noise is plus
one everywhere then it looks like it's
the one function and so you're just
gonna get a 1 plus epsilon approximation
because if you have bias then that can
confusing but still you can get a 1 plus
epsilon approximation
but there's this K and this K right so
right so you also need the K log D and
you have this K that's necessary and it
comes and it's necessary as you see from
the polynomials if I don't take these
square examples I'm not going to see
anything there and adversarial annoys
can make it look at just like the zero
function and so the question is can we
avoid this dependence on K but through
some other other way of accessing the
data that's what the focus of talk is
gonna be so particularly I look at other
access patterns where we don't get our
samples X uniformly at random but we
were able to choose them in some way so
then we can bias do some sort of
important sampling towards the more
important part parts of the space so we
can decrease the sample complexity and
in particular the goal is going to be to
replace K which is the maximum value
over all x over the maximum value over
all functions of n of x squared with
kappa which is the expected value over x
of the maximum value of x squared and so
for polynomials what happens is that if
there exists polynomials that are very
high variance on the edges but in the
center you don't have you can't be
nearly as high and you're in your
variance relative to your average and so
the average value of the of the of the
importance of an X is not so large into
the Jessica order day in fact for any
linear space of functions you can show
that cap is equal to D and then for such
folks so so then in the query model
which is where you can choose your X's
of your choice and then you're gonna see
why I drawn from the distribution for a
given X then in this model if we get we
and and then where's d come in where the
distribution well the only point of the
distribution was if you can choose X is
that this measures your norm of error so
let's suppose we know it because like I
care about learning in an in l2 so this
is sort of the typical model for things
like sparse first thing
um surprise recovery where you can
choose the points to look at as far as
for answers you can choose the points to
look at and then you care about your
average l2 error but we're also going to
look at the active learning model which
is that as well in all situations you
can't you don't have full choice you
can't choose any X that you want but you
get a large collection of X's that are
unlabeled that's that unlabeled data is
a lot cheaper than label data and it
takes humans to label data so you're
going to give you a large collection of
unlabeled data and now you're gonna
choose a subset of the points to send to
a human to get labels for and you pay
you pay for that and now you want to
minimize most importantly the number of
labeled examples you get but less
importantly the number of unlabeled
examples you yeah so we're gonna you get
a sample of M points x1 through XM and
we're gonna choose a subset and then
we're gonna see the corresponding Y for
those that subset and now we want to
learn for learn a function that's good
on average over the distribution and
there we go so this so these are for a
linear space of functions you get some
some results for nonlinear functions as
well okay
so let's start with the simplest setting
of just trying to get something that
doesn't depend on the condition number
in the query model so one that's right
so of all the intuition comes from
trying to just approximate the norm of
functions in in our class and this took
as we saw K log D samples
to approximate particularly it certainly
takes K samples to get anything in the
edge but if we do some important
sampling then we're going to say that
we're going to sample more towards the
edges if I sample in particular if I
sample from not the original
distribution D of X but a revision D
prime of X that scales up X by how big
the value could be in the ERM
calculation and this isn't normalized
you need to divide by the average of
this what is the average of this well
it's the expectation of the stoop of f
of X squared was exactly the kappa that
we defined before so now if we if we
sample from stable points according to
this D prime then basically just as in
Moses of chalk before me now we're gonna
let me ask you eight there nor we need
to we need to scale down again because
we get it now we get points with
probability D prime we want to estimate
the sum the expectation of D of X with
some D of x times f of X so we just had
so then in our in our estimate of the
norm under D we're gonna have the
average of D over D prime time to f of X
square so now you say okay how fast is
this going to converge to the correct
answer well it's going to depend on so
know the turn off bound is going to
depend on how big these values are it's
going to depend on the supremum of this
what is the scream of this
well the d of x is cancel the supremum
right f of X is less than this repeal of
f of X and so you get exactly Kappa so
the saying that the values in that were
summing and taking the average of have
gone from k to kappa and so the number
of samples are going to take for this to
converge is going to go from k which was
the supreme over
except the supreme ORF 2 kappa which is
the expectation over exodus cream over
this is going to say that we can now we
can estimate the normal functions with
samples that are like catalog D and then
yes is it clear that this like couldn't
there be for NEX an F in your family
that the supreme is the worst case this
there probably are right for polynomials
that are certainly are but the point is
that so so what made this what made
polynomials bad was that the supreme
here was deep and while the average was
just one right the serum was d times the
average but if you set X to be zero the
mr. premium can't be D times the average
because it's constrained on both sides
and the stream can only be square root D
times the average and if you look at all
of them on average the squared value can
be in most order D times yeah
it's a particular for any for any linear
space kappa disorder dean so this would
give you order d log these samples so
just to give a simple proof of that if
you just take your function in your
linear space express it in this
orthonormal basis so f of X is the sum
over J of alpha J times Phi J for some
orthonormal functions Phi J and there's
a premium over F of f of x squared where
F has norm one under a distribution what
does that mean that means that the
decomposition has alpha J's having l
2-norm one of then alpha dot you can
think of the vector alpha dot the Phi J
of X is gonna be the value at F of x
squared and now what is this well the
supreme so if I take an inner product
squared and the supreme over all thing
all alpha of l 2-norm one gonna be
maximized if alpha is in the direction
of this vector so i said alpha to be Phi
J divided by this norm and so you could
value again it's exactly the sum of Phi
J of x squared and now the expectation
of this is going to be e D so for linear
spaces this expected soup is exactly D
and so your this gives the order d log D
bound
okay so so far what this says is that if
we sample or points X so that we really
up sample proportional to the stream of
f of x squared then we get an order D
log D sample complexity and this is
essentially the same as every score
sampling right and so really what I
think is right so in terms of estimating
the norm this is basically what you
would get from our square sampling the
other aspect of it is showing that the
noise behaves well because you don't
have if you're if you're familiar
understand score sampling you don't have
any we're not looking at the noise and
so we so this doesn't guarantee that the
noise is good but because your service
or sampling is is well spread out you
can show it's bounded an expectation you
can also think of lower score sampling
is out as analogous to streaming service
tava grass specification and so then the
question is well that's an N log n grass
versification can we use linear samples
for education and so you can't with
independent sampling you can show again
by coupon collector that if your x1 and
x2 we up to XD are all drawn from the
same distribution then you knew a need D
log D samples but if you do it with non
independent sampling then in fact you
can avoid this so this is analogous to
BSS which is the linear space sample
across sophistication but BSS doesn't
work for this setting because exactly
its terminus neck and if your
deterministic then that means you choose
your points X determine a fixed set so
if I want to learn a degree D
polynomials I'm going to look at x1
equals 0.5 and x2 equals 0.7 and so on
but then my noise is just bounded on
average in two it could be adversarial
and placed entirely on those positions
and so you can't get any guarantee so
you need to realize version of VSS and
that's in fact known so Lee's son gave a
randomized
method for sparsa fication and we show
that that suffice is for this problem
that the randomization is enough to make
your error rebounded in expectation okay
so just and then just the guarantee that
you get again is that for mean zero
noise our error relative is is epsilon
times the nor knows you have and for
generic noise or error is 1 plus epsilon
okay
this is for the query model but as I was
saying in a lot of situations you don't
you can't choose the X's as you want and
you don't know what the distribution on
axis is instead you have a collection of
unlabeled data you want to choose which
ones to get labels for so this is now
the active learning setting so again my
label data we want to choose a subset to
get labels for and there's two goals now
right so we want to minimize both the
number of unlabeled points we need and
the number of label points we need so
you can ask okay suppose you only care
about minimizing one of those in
isolation so if we only cared about
minimizing the number of labeled points
what is that well we're gonna choose
infinitely many unlabeled points because
there's no cost what happens if we do
that well now we learn the distribution
because we get it for the many samples
for the distribution and we can query
any point we want in the support of the
distribution because we have all the
points this is precisely the query model
so it's the size of the query model that
means that we know that theta of the
samples is necessary and sufficient for
at least four linear spaces
okay so now suppose we only cared about
minimizing em and not ass said what we
do will we just label everything because
there's no cost to choosing everything
to live for labeling everything then
we're in the agnostic setting because
you don't really have any choice we're
just getting a bunch of labeled points
XY so they lost exciting that means we
need K log D plus K over epsilon then
our result of that in fact both of those
you can get at the same time there's not
a trade-off between these two parameters
this many say this many unlabeled points
is enough to learn and off by your
distribution to do a theta of the label
points and this talk I'll mostly cover
the letter score sampling based order D
log DS version but then I'll give a
little intuition for how you have the
order D sample algorithm works there has
been prior work so there was a result of
cilantro and Munoz that got D log D to
the 5/4 pound and then there was some
concurrent work very recently that got
an order D log D bound using not levered
score sampling but volume sampling and
weight and that's another algorithm
actually that may well get an order D
bound but we don't know how to prove it
okay so the questions are on our goal
actually get
they actually got um they okay so I
think they they don't look they don't
actually look at the difference between
they don't really look at going from
error on x1 through XM to error on the
distribution so we're saying that we're
gonna we're gonna generalize as well as
do what not just do well on the on the
empirical distribution I don't think
they do that but that's actually not
really the hard part of them yeah
basically because the matrix turn off if
you do if you do generalize on x1
through XM then you're gonna generalize
on the rest of the description okay
so let's earn with the warrant right so
there's two different there's two
distinctions between the active learning
setting and the queries having right
there's that we we don't know the
distribution team you need to learn it
from our samples and they can't quite
any point where you want we can only
query the points that we've seen so far
so start with just getting halfway there
by saying suppose we know the
distribution but we can't shoot at any
point we want we can only choose the
points that we've sampled we have the
unlabeled samples form so in this
setting we can now simulate the query
algorithm where we wanted to a sample
proportional to this D prime by
rejection sampling so that means that
whenever so we want a sample points
proportional to D of x times the soup
over f of f of x squared it will just
label choose to label any point that we
get with probability proportional to
this and we're proportional to this that
means the probability has to be less
than one so the scaling factor is going
to be dividing by the maximum value this
could take the maximum value this could
take is exactly okay so I'm gonna say
we're gonna label each point X sign
we're probably equal to one over K times
this so now it would we do this the
number of labeled samples we're going to
need is just d log D because we're
getting now getting our labeled examples
exactly from the distribution we wanted
for the query outcome now the question
is how many late how many unlabeled
examples do we need in order for this to
work in order to get the number of label
examples we need well the chance that
any late so if you think about any
example coming in what is the
probability that a given that a random
example coming in is going to be labeled
is the expectation over x2 the
probability that you're labeled well
that's the expected soup divided by the
K which is cap over K and so this says
that in order to get which is D over K
so in order to get the D log D samples
that we need to have labeled we just
need K log D samples on labeled
and so that means that the K lagdi
unlabeled samples and D log D label
samples are exactly what we need to get
the active learning guarantee in this
simpler warm-up where we know the
district we know the distribution this
week that's what we don't know the
distribution well where does this
algorithm use the distribution
because once we sampled it we just are
doing some erm so the algorithm once you
get there samples it doesn't actually
use the distribution the only place
where you this distribution is designed
the probability of sampling and where do
you use the distribution and assign the
probability is that the diffusion
appears right here then we look at all
function their class and we take f of x
squared divided by the expected value of
f of X squared under X from our
distribution that means all we need from
the disputer to be able to estimate the
norms of functions in our class so so we
need to a straight norm of the functions
our class but that is exactly what
matrix turning off said you could do
with K log D
so you just need to learn these things
need to learn the aspirate the norms of
functions okay like these samples of ice
so this means we can do it in K lagdi
samples and D log D label examples
so now let's let's briefly describe how
to improve this from D log D down to
order D samples and so the d log D comes
from coupon collector so if you just
think like if my distribution on X is
that if the domain is one through D so X
is either 1 or 2 or 3 up to D then I
need to choose at least one of each of
those points if I choose from
independently from some distribution I
gotta miss some point so I need to have
it I need to now have a dependent
distribution in order to do order D
samples and so in particular we're going
to say is we're going to start out
sampling from this distribution that we
liked for the first point but now once
we have an X we don't mean no longer
need to get points that are the same is
we're going to bias our future examples
away from the points that we've seen so
far
we're gonna choose the I'd example from
a distribution di that depends on that
depends on all the points we've seen so
far but it doesn't depend on the
examples we've seen so far
notice you can still do this for active
learning because we know which points
with rows we select and then we're gonna
need two properties for for our set out
a collection of di in order for this to
work so the first probability is that we
need to be able to preserve the norms
right so we really need to do something
like matrix turn off that took K log D
where we knew that that took D log D
samples for from from leverage score
sampling but then we also need to have
our noise being bounded because we need
to say something about how the BSS
linear linear sample specification
doesn't work because it's deterministic
right there need the our samples need to
be random enough that the noise doesn't
concentrate it messes
into the first property of having the
norms preserved is saying that well
right so naively you just say that your
average value of D over D di F of x
squared is close to the actual
expectation and the noise variance being
bounded is turns out okay so it's a
little bit of calculation is saying that
each individual distribution di has a
bounded condition number and as long as
each one is found in a condition number
and that's going to say that the
variance due to the noise is small and
you can show that the expectation do the
noise is zero now this we don't actually
know how to prove you can only prove it
where you replace the 1 over s by some
alpha I that depend on the distributions
but you do it it's a little bit messy
anyway
so you can do this with lease on
fortification if you analyze look
carefully at how they how they do this
so that basically they were focused on
the norm preservation but you can show
that the sample the distribution that
they pick also give you the noise
variance band than you need so this is
also far yes
[Music]
so your adaptive to the exes that you've
chosen but you don't look at the wise at
all and so you're still doing it for
active learning record yeah I mean it
just is like eventually you're just
getting some joint distribution over
your exes
and you're not looking at anything it's
just a way of computing a joint
distribution now I think it is
right
I think it's an interesting question
whether you could whether you could like
give an explicit statement for the
distribution like for polynomials you
can choose you can say we're gonna pick
one sample from the outside one where D
Square and another sample from the next
two over T squared and so on and that
works and we don't know how to do that
in general but yeah so this is this is
adaptive but it's not - anything that
you learn and so it's still
yeah so the last bit of my talk I'll
discuss an extension to nonlinear spaces
so rather than what happens if you're
not a linear function but for example a
sparse Fourier transform so here now our
function class is that f of X is the sum
over our D points of V J times e to the
2 pi I F J X where f J is the frequency
V J is the value and we're gonna have no
assumptions on our V J's and our f J's
are going and almost no episodes are
after James right so we're gonna allow
them to be very very close to each other
they're gonna be bounded or something
and again we're gonna say you can sample
points suppose we want you can sample
them uniformly in some interval example
them however you wanted some interval
you're gonna measure our error as just
l2 norm over this interval you can think
of this as people playing music
relatively a few frequencies going on
and we're listening for a finite period
of time and we can choose what points in
this time that we're going to sample and
see that see the value that we're
getting and
so again we're gonna need to be able if
you want to do this well we're gonna
need to be able to estimate the norm of
this function and we're gonna escalate
the norm of this function then that's
gonna depend as we saw from the
beginning the talk on the soup soup
divided by the expected that the soup of
the soup divided by the expected value
and you can show that if you set your f
JS if you set them all to be converging
to 0 then by a Taylor expansion you can
actually express any polynomial as a
limiting value of this class so the set
of sparse for your representations is
larger than the set of degree D
polynomials and so in particular we know
that it's got to be at least D at least
d squared is K but we need to analyze it
there so again my uniform sampling is
going to depend on the soup soup we
don't know what this soup soup is for
sparse Fourier transforms without with
continuous frequencies but so we along
with a java song and Daniel Caine we're
able to show that it's at most D to the
fourth times some log factors and we
know that it's at least d squared by
this relation to polynomials and so this
Venn gives you a sample complexity bound
but we can do the leverage score
sampling style important sampling where
if we pick a point proportional to its
we pick a point proportional to the soup
over f of f of x squared and then our
estimate of the norm is going to
proportional to Kappa and we can show
that Kappa for sparse Fourier transforms
is basically D so we've gone down from
this somewhere between d squared and D
to the fourth we're not sure - somewhere
between D and D log squared D as the
number of samples required to estimate a
single a single function
to this if you're familiar this is
analogous to the sting ssin between the
Markov bread for polynomials there's the
Markov brothers inequality which bounds
the maximum value polynomial can take in
terms of its average by d squared and
there's the bernstein inequality which
surrounds the value the expected value
yeah the the ' she brothers applies
phosphate yeah so they're two two
Markov's that jointly did this like an
equality in the late nineteenth century
right it's actually kind of funny but
because it in my concentration
inequalities we also have a markov
inequality and a Bernstein's inequality
these are not those these are different
inequalities that are still very related
to each other yeah ok so just as it as a
sketch of this proof we so take the
degree D polynomial P of Z whose roots
are at e to the 2 pi F J Delta this
color no meal is going to depend on FJ
is gonna depend on this Delta it doesn't
depend on exactly what X you're looking
at for f of X and then if you look at
any position X and you evaluate this
expression the sum over all I of beta I
f of X plus Delta I this is just a
linear a linear combination of an
arithmetic sequence of positions of
looking at this at this function then
this if you expand your definition of F
and you transpose now you switch the
order of summation you can show that
this is a linear combination of the
evaluations of P where is equal to 0 so
just to the illustrate what's going on
we're saying we have our function f that
has its first Fourier transform we look
at a sequence of D
positions that are each separated by
Delta and we're saying that there exists
a linear combination the sum of beta I
times this value times it plus the beta
1 times this plus beta 2 times this and
so on such that this sum is equal to 0
here and it's equal to 0 here and it's
equal to 0 here that is equal to 0
regardless of what position or offset X
you have and what that means then is
particular if you look at the largest
coefficient you have it says that the
value that F takes that X plus I star
Delta is certainly at most the sum of
the values it takes at the other
positions because the sum of all of them
is equal to 0 and what that would mean
is that the value that F takes in any
position X there's bounded by the sum of
the values it takes it in an arithmetic
sequence going going moving outside it
and if you do a little bit more care you
can change this from an absolute value
can find maybe if you do it work here
you can find a seat you can find a set
of d of these or d different linear
combinations that are orthogonal to each
other or most two orthogonal to each
other and so you can replace this l1
bound with an l2 bound up to some
constants so you can see that the value
that f of x squared is is bounded by the
sum of the f of X Squared's in an
internet exceeds the value around this
position and that then means that if you
then just integrate Delta from 0 to 1
over D or to the like 1 minus x over D
you could say that the value that f of X
takes at any position X is bounded by
its average value times D divided by 1
minus the distance this says that if X
is not very very near the edges that f
of x squared can't be too big
so then you get a bound on the expected
value that I have x-squared can take and
this then gives you a bound on the
sample complexity required to learn as
far as Fourier transforms in the
continuous setting so this so so then
the point is we showed is active
learning can be optimally both of the
criteria of K log D plus K reps on
unlabeled examples and order D over
epsilon label examples and we can also
get some improvement for for a sparse X
now what I showed you was basically
tight at least up to these log factors
we don't have the analogous bound to
matrix turn off and so there's a there's
a dependence on the net size that's not
optimal I think some interesting
questions for future work are one going
beyond l2 and linear spaces so for
example can we do logistic regression
and another is for in when people
actually do active learning they'll
often sample points and then do multiple
around so after you look at some points
decide where to sample next and in this
worst case agnostic setting that's not
useful and I think it's a good question
whether it is useful for worst case
bounds it's something that can I just
digression or what you should be doing
for other things
[Applause]
so but nonlinear spaces could you
approximate the Lamia faction abound
alone nonlinear function by polynomials
and then but how many polynomials is it
gonna take right so if like yeah so so
for example for sports for a a there you
have this if you have high frequencies
then they're spinning around very fast
and it will take a very high degree
polynomial it will I wouldn't be bounded
in terms of D would help me if they gave
you boundary conditions because it looks
like that's pretty you your analysis
boundary what sort of boundary
conditions are you thinking oh if you're
something from 0 to 1 they give you a
zero level one
I mean you can argue the best nose does
exterior
I mean if you just told me I was zero
enough of one then you can still make
I think with no noise
this interesting question right so if
you're allowed to have noise so in our
model
I can't just query after zero now the
one because I think I would have noise
and so I can't trust the points that I
would get yeah maybe you can get better
results if you're sure if you're
confident they're values
thank you
[Applause]